This video is brought to you by people just
like you.
People who watch and enjoy the videos we put
out every single week.
But the specific people who have made this
video possible are our supporters on Patreon.
They signed up to give us a monthly contribution
that goes directly into the production of
these episodes.
So, we’d like to start off today by saying
thank you to them, and if you’d like to
join them you can go to patreon.com/journeytomicro
and sign up today.
Pond scum is kind of a rude name, isn’t
it?
I mean, sure, it feels kind of appropriate
when you’re wading through murky waters,
and you feel that disconcerting combination
of fuzzy and slick textures sliding against
the bottom of your feet.
You might not be able to see it,
but you can sure feel it—
whether or not you want to.
And it feels like anything could be there,
anything at all.
But even still.
Scum?
That seems a little judgmental.
Technically, the word “scum” was originally
used in the 14th century to describe the frothy
layers on top of liquids.
It wasn’t until the 16th century that it began
to be used more as an insult against people.
So sure, “scum” was probably meant more
to describe the way pond scum obscures our
water than as a moral criticism of those green
mats.
But there is actually something kind of…
scummy about pond scum.
It’s not something they necessarily intend
to be.
In fact, it’s a contradiction of sorts,
a process that takes them from an organism
that provides oxygen to its fellow pond neighbors,
to an organism that suffocates them.
There are different types of green that accumulate
in our ponds, including clouds of cyanobacteria
that disperse when you wave a stick through
them.
But pond scum is different.
If you drag a stick through pond scum, it’ll
come out of the water looking like a wet mat
woven together with green threads.
It looks like that, because that is what pond
scum is.
Those mats are made out of filamentous algae,
a range of species who bring a mixture of
greens and yellows and browns to their joint
endeavor.
Up close, with a microscope, you can see the
individual characteristics that make up those
algae, almost as if you’re examining the
silk threads that have been stitched together
to form a glorious tapestry.
And by “glorious tapestry,” we of course
mean “pond scum.”
And yes, that feels like a contradiction.
But look at these Spirogyra and their distinct
spiral shape that their chloroplasts wind
through them.
They’re like a spectacular off-color candy
cane.
When you feel pond scum on you, this is what
you’re feeling:
beautiful microscopic strands built from chains
of cells that divide and divide to elongate
the thread binding their lives together.
Filamentous algae usually begin growing at
the bottom of ponds, in shallow areas where
there is plenty of light to drive their photosynthesis.
As the algae divides and extends its chains,
the filaments begin to tangle and weave together,
forming a dense mat.
Because the algae are photosynthesizing, they
are also releasing oxygen into the water—
oxygen that gets trapped as bubbles within
the growing mat.
Those bubbles lift the mat of filamentous
algae up so that it’s no longer trapped
at the bottom of the pond.
And that creates a sort of floating city,
with threads of algae that house many residents
of the microcosmos.
In the background here, you can see the blurry
form of a rotifer snapping up any snack that
passes close enough for it to grasp.
And here we can see a strange hypotrich popping
out from underneath a filament as it feeds,
maybe using the algae like a log to hide under
before it ambushes its unsuspecting prey.
And if you look hard enough, you might find
an aeolosoma, our favorite polka-dotted worm,
sandwiched between strands of algae,
maybe casually wiggling around
on its way to a cannibalistic gathering.
(Yes, that’s a thing.
We have a whole episode about it, if you want
to know more.)
All-in-all, it turns out that pond scum is
both made of beautiful algae threads, and
houses all sorts of fascinating creatures.
You might be tempted to call it a little microbial
utopia.
But James, our master of microscopes, often
gets emails from people who want to know how
to get rid of the scum growing in their artificial
ponds.
“But they’re so wonderful,” you might
say, now that you know that underlying all
that muck is a wondrous world of worms and
rotifers and mysterious creatures housed in
a living home that sustains them.
And yet every year, ponds around the world
become the site of a battle between the filamentous
algae that come to dominate them, and…
well, pretty much everything else in the pond.
This is a different situation from, say, the
cyanobacteria we mentioned earlier, or certain
algal blooms, that can kill their fellow pond
residents by producing toxins.
Filamentous algae wouldn’t do something
nefarious like poison their neighbors.
They just suffocate them instead.
The organisms living inside ponds rely on
oxygen that gets dissolved in the water.
Some of that oxygen comes from outside the
pond, diffusing and circulating into the water.
But of course, filamentous algae and their
fellow photosynthetic pond residents contribute
to the oxygen content as well.
Which is quite kind of the filamentous algae.
The problem is that they don’t just make
oxygen.
They also consume it.
And if the weather conditions aren’t quite
right, the algae will consume more oxygen
than they make.
This depletion can be exacerbated by nutrients
like phosphorus and nitrogen, which might
enter the pond from fertilizer or runoff from
around the pond.
These nutrients cause the algae to grow and
grow and grow until their numbers skew the
oxygen balance in their favor and against
everyone else’s.
And even if the algae die off all at once—
like through the use of a chemical algaecide—
that doesn’t solve the oxygen problem.
You’ve now provided the bacteria
in the pond plenty of dead algae to decompose,
which means they consume a lot of oxygen instead.
That doesn’t mean that you can’t use chemicals
to kill algae.
However, it requires careful consideration
of the pond conditions and the algae involved
to make sure that it makes sense to turn to
those algaecides.
There are other methods for short-term control
of these algae populations.
Like physically removing them with a rake,
or using water-soluble dyes that limit sunshine
to the algae when they’re still at the bottom
of ponds.
But these are short-term solutions.
The fact is that long-term approaches means
preventing excess nutrients from entering
the ponds in the first place, whether by thinking
through our fertilizer choices or adding buffers
to our ponds that prevent runoff from entering
or any number of other approaches that help
maintain a healthy pond.
Because maybe in the long-term, dealing with
filamentous algae is rooted in acknowledging
the way they suit the word “scum” in all
senses of the word.
They are grimy and gross, but also something
that is simply a part of the water.
And in between the negative connotations of
the word and its more neutral origins is something
wondrous that requires balance on our end
to maintain.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
Those names you’re seeing on the screen
right now are some of our Patreon patrons,
and they are the reason that this show can
exist.
If you’d like to join them in supporting
Journey To The Microcosmos, you can go to
patreon.com/journeytomicro to get weekly wallpapers
and monthly uncut videos
If you’d like to see more from our Master
of MIcroscopes, James Weiss, you can check
out Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you’d like to see more from us, there’s
probably a subscribe button somewhere nearby.